we had a very intensive
lunch today, also with the vice president
card one, where we clearly
stated that industrial policy is an
essential pillar in europe for
securing prosperity and
jobs. this also requires
a monitoring mechanism, which
we decided on today  Monitoring
mechanism that also shows where industry
is in Europe at the moment and where
it will be going in the future.
Industrial policy is not something that
we can see separately from the
areas of smolen media, i.e.
small, medium-sized companies and the
start-up area, but as an image
eco system that can only be successful together
our task here
is to ensure that europe does not
fall behind we have
a different point here together and have certainly sent a
strong signal that
industrial policy is important for us
together
a holistic
approach is also needed  the Wu  rde discussed the
second essential bay was the
internal market the digital internal market
I am very pleased that we were able
to advance the file platform to business reason
and conclude
zé roberto the hand of the water of the 5
[music]